اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات في
العناوين
اسرائيل تتاهب على حدود غزه بعد غارات على
القطاع قتلت 13 فلسطينيا بينهم ثلاثه من
قاده الجهاد
حركه الجهات تتوعد اسرائيل برد سريع
والخارجيه الفلسطينيه تطالب بتدخل دولي
عاجل لوقف التصعيد
وتزامنا مع غارات غزه القوات الاسرائيليه
تقتحم البلده القديمه في نابلس وتشتبك مع
فلسطينيين
روسيا تحتفل بعيد النصر وتواصل حمله
الغارات المكثفه على اوكرانيا والاخيره
تعلن التصدي للهجمات
اهلا بكم في ساعه مبكره من صباح اليوم
الثلاثاء شنت القوات الاسرائيليه هجوما
على قطاع غزه باربعين طائره حربيه مطلقه
على هذه العمليه اسم الدرع والسهم اسرائيل
قالت انها قصفت عشره مواقع لانتاج الاسلحه
اضافه لمجمعات عسكريه تابعه لحركه الجهاد
وادت هذه الغارات الى مقتل 13 شخصا واصابه
عشرين اخرين نتيجه القصف وذلك بحسب وزاره
الصحه في غزه بينهم ثلاثه من قاده حركه
الجهاد واوضح الجيش الاسرائيلي في بيان
رسمي اغتيال قائد المنطقه الشماليه في
الجهاد خليل البهتيمي الذي تتهمه اسرائيل
بالوقوف خلف اطلاق الصواريخ صوب مناطق
غلاف غزه خلال الاشهر الماضيه كما اغتالت
الغارات الاسرائيليه امين سر المجلس
العسكري لسرايا القدس جهاد غنام اضافه
الاغتيال طارق عز الدين المسؤول عن توجيه
عدد من العمليات في الضفه الغربيه كما
واعلنت اسرائيل مشاهدينا حاله طوارئ في
الجبهه الداخليه وطالبت من المستوطنين
البقاء بعيدين عن حدوث قطاع غزه حتى 40
كيلو متر والبقاء قربه الملاجئ في حين
علقت غزه دوام المؤسسات التعليميه واجلت
اختباراتها حتى اشعار اخر
[موسيقى]
حركه الجهاد مشاهدينا هددت في قطاع غزه
هددت اسرائيل بان ردها لن يتاخر على هجمات
تل ابيب والتي استهدفت مواقع الحركه في
القطاع فجره اليوم وحملت الحركه اسرائيل
كامل المسؤوليه عن ما وصفته بالمجزره
الارهابيه والتي اكدت انها تشكل انتهاكا
خطيرا لوقف اطلاق النار وفق بيان الحركه
وكانت قد نعت الحركه حركه الجهاد 13 فلس
بينهم اطفال وثلاثه من قاده الحركه قتلوا
في الغارات الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه
الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول عقب الضربات الجويه
ومقتل فلسطينيين انها عمليه عسكريه
استهداف مواقع وقاده بارزين من حركه
الجهاد اطلق عليها اسم السهم الواقي
مسؤولون فلسطينيون اكدوا مقتل ثلاثه من
قاده الجهات في الغارات ومدنيين بينهم
اطفال الجيش الاسرائيلي قال في بيان ان
قواته شنت هجمات مركزه على القطاع طالت
عشره مواقع لانتاج اسلحه ومجمعات عسكريه
لحركه الجهاد وفق بيان الدفاع الاسرائيليه
وان العمليه التي خطط لها الثلاثاء الماضي
شاركت فيها اربعون طائره وقال ان ثلاثه من
قاده الجهاد وهم قائد منطقه شمال قطاع غزه
في حركه الجهاد وقيادي بارز في الحركه
المسؤول عن توجيه نشاطات في الضفه الغربيه
انطلاقا من غزه وايضا امين سر المجلس
العسكري هذا وفق البيان الاسرائيلي
حركه الجهات قالت ان ثلاثه من ابرز قادتها
في القطاع هم خليل البهتيني وطارق عز
الدين وجهاد غنام قتلوا خلال الضربات
الاسرائيليه
متوعده بالرد وتكبيد اسرائيل ثمنا كبيرا
لعمليتها في غزه كما شددت على عدم مغادره
مواقعها في القطاع اما وزاره الصحه في غزه
فاعلنت انه اضافه الى مقتل واصابه العشرات
تعمل طواقم الاسعاف على اجلاء الضحايا من
المناطق التي تم قصفها
ومع استمرار التصعيد في غزه اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الاسرائيليه موافقه وزيرها على
استدعاء قوات الاحتياط حسب متطلبات الجيش
والحاجه لمشاركتهم في مواجهات محتمله جاسم
محسن العربيه
مباشره من حدود قطاع غزه ينضم الينا مدير
مكتب العربيه زياد حلبي اهلا بك معنا زياد
اذا انت تطل علينا من الحدود وكونك هناك
هل بالفعل رايت ايتها تاهب امني اسرائيل
تاهب جوي كما تتحدث الانباء انقل لنا
الصوره لديك زياد
بدون ان نشاك هذا صحيح كما يمكن ان تريخ
بطاريه القبه الحديديه من خلفنا يمكن ان
تروها الان بشكل اوضح نحن قريبون من هذا
من هذه البطاريه على حدود قطاع غزه هذه
الحدود اغلقت بالكامل بطبيعه الحال باتت
منطقه عسكريه مغلقه بالنسبه لاسرائيليين
كما ايضا لاحظنا حركه نشطه لسلاح الجو
الاسرائيلي في سماء المنطقه
انتظارا على الارجح لما تتوقعه اسرائيل من
اطلاق الجهاد الاسلامي عشرات الصواريخ
دفعه واحده تجاه المستوطنات القريبه
والبعيده الاسرائيليه بعد انتهاء عمليات
التشييع في قطاع غزه هذا هو التوقع
الاساسي وما يزال السؤال الاساسي لدى
الاسرائيليين عمليا هو هل سيكون هناك
التزام بين مزدوجين طبعا بقواعد الاشتباك
بمعنى حتى 40 كيلومترا عن الحدود قطاع غزه
ام ان الامور ستذهب الى مدن اعمق وابعد من
ذلك باستهداف تل ابيب كما سبق وانفعلت
حركه الجهاد الاسلامي ايا كان التاهب هو
في كافه المناطق على كافه الجبهات في
الشمال والوسط والجنوب عوده اسرائيل
الاغتيالات قاده
بالميدان يعني ميدانيين وفي قطاع غزه
تحديدا كيف يقرا في الداخل الفلسطيني زياد
يعني هل هناك تصعيد متوقع هل هناك مزيد من
الصواريخ
يعني الاطلاق للصواريخ وبين الجهاد
الاسلامي والفصائل الفلسطينيه واسرائيل
هذا صحيح هذا ما سيكون بعد قليل عمليا
سنبدا برؤيه هذا الامر اطلاق صواريخ من
قطاع غزه تجاهه المستوطنات الاسرائيليه
واتجاه ربما العمق الاسرائيلي بدون ادنى
شك بان العوده الى الاغتيالات بعد اكثر من
سنه عمليا
حكومه لبيد السابقه فعلت الامر ذاته عندما
لجات وبادرت الى اغتيال قاده ميدانيين
للجهاد الاسلامي عندها كنا امام ايام من
القتال شهدت ايضا اطلاق صواريخ على تل
ابيب هذا السيناريو يتكرر الان السبب في
ذلك بالنسبه للمراقبين اقله بالنسبه
لاسرائيل هو ان اسرائيل تحاول ان تعيد
عمليا ما يسمى قدره الردع لديها بعد ان
تضررت الى حد الانتهاء على جبهه قطاع غزه
كما هي الحال على جبهه لبنان بمعنى
الجبهات يفعل بعضها بعضا في كل مره وجوله
جوله تصعيد تق جوله اخرى اسرائيل تحاول ان
تجعل المساحه الزمنيه المسافه الزمنيه بين
الجولات اطول زمنيا نحن نتحدث عن الثلاثاء
الماضي الجوله الاخيره التي كانت قصيره مع
الجهاد الاسلامي ايضا
وبالتالي الان هذه تتمه لهذه الجوله ولكن
بدون ان شك بعد اللجوء الى اغتيالات
اسرائيل تعرف بان الرد لن يكون ردا مقتضبا
طيب يعني هذه الغارات الاخيره التي شنت
على قطاع غزه وصفت بالمفاجاه زياد يعني من
اين اتت ما الغرض منها هل هي لمكاسب
اسرائيليه سياسيه داخليه ربما ام هناك سبب
اخر غير مفهوم غير معلوم حتى الان
قد تكون لتحقيق مجموعه من الاهداف
المرسومه كما قلنا بالنسبه لاسرائيل هناك
ترهل الى حد يعني شبه انهيار لقدره الردع
امام الفصائل في قطاع غزه ربما اسرائيل
تعتقد بان الاغتيالات لقيادات وكوادر
عمليا عسكريه بارزه قد يقود الى ردع ما
هذا الامر الاول الامر الثاني بدون ادنى
شك الواقع الداخلي الاسرائيلي قد يكون له
دور في هذا الموضوع لان التحذيرات التي
كانت من الجيش الاسرائيلي حتى في الاونه
الاخيره بان الازمه الداخليه في اسرائيل
تقرا او خارجيا وهنا وضعفا وقد تغري
الاخرين لتجريب ذلك امنيا وعسكريا كما حدث
في المره الاخيره اطلاق صواريخ من لبنان
عشرات الصواريخ وتفعيل جبهه قطاع غزه
الامر الاخر بالنسبه لنتنياهو بدوده ان شك
لا يضره بي ان التعبير هكذا تصعيد لعده
ايام على جبهه قطاع غزه بعد ان يكون نفذ
اغتيالات لاسترضاء الشارع اليميني راينا
فقط من المره الاخيره الثلاثاء الماضي
بنجفير وزير الامن الداخلي القومي المتطرف
يقاطع التصويت في الكنيسه لصالح الحكومه
يقاطع جلسات الحكومه وقال ان ذلك بسبب
الرد الهزيل الاسرائيلي على الفصائل في
قطاع غزه الان سيعود للاحضان
النتدياهو والحكومه بدون ادنى شكل وطبعا
حرف الانظار عن الازمه الداخليه بالنسبه
لنتنياهو ايضا اعلاميا امر جيد عمليا لان
الاعلام الاسرائيلي في مثل هذه الحالات
يصبح مجندا بالكامل لصالح الجيش والحكومه
في الاداء بمعنى لا تسمعين انتقادات حول
التصعيد الحالي اقله الى حين انتهاء هذا
التصعيد شكرا لك مباشره من حدود قط اع غزه
مدير مكتب العربيه زياد حلبي
وبالتزامن مع الهجوم الذي شنته على قطاع
غزه نفذت القوات الاسرائيليه عمليه في
نابلس شمال الضفه الغربيه اصيب على اثرها
طفل فلسطيني بالرصاص الحي واقتحمت القوات
الاسرائيليه البلده القديمه بالاليات
وحاصرت منزلا في حي الياسمينه وسط سماع
ليدوي فجار وسط نابلس ووقوع اشتباكات بين
الجيش الاسرائيلي ومسلحين فلسطينيين في
البلده القديمه وافاد مراسل العربيه حول
ذلك ان القوات الاسرائيليه انسحبت من
المدينه في وقت لاحق
[موسيقى]
شعوا بشعه معنى من نابلس مراسل العربيه
خالد قاسم اهلا بك معنا خالد اذا انسحبت
القوات الاسرائيليه من النابلس ولكن كان
هناك طفل اصيب برصاص حي وكان هناك قبل
انسحابهم ايضا اشتباكات انقل لنا
المعلومات المتوفره لديك حول ذلك
بحسب شهود العيان فاطمه
اكتشف الفلسطينيون
وحده خاصه ترتدي الزي الفلسطيني بمحيط
البلده القديمه وجرت العاده في مثل هذه
الحالات تطلق صافرات الانذار في مدينه
نابلس ومخيماتها بعدها توغلت الاليات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه من جميع المناطق
الجيش الاسرائيلي حاصر منزلا في حاره
القريون جنوبيه البلده القديمه من مدينه
نابلس وامطره بالرصاص وقذائف انيرجي حدثت
هناك اشتباكات ومواجهات بين الفلسطينيين
والقوات الاسرائيليه التي ساندت الوحدات
الخاصه هذه الاشتباكات ادت الى اصابه فتى
فلسطينيه يبلغ من العمر 14 عاما برصاصه في
الصدر قال الناطق باسم وزاره الصحه بان
حالته مستقره كما العديد من الاصابات
وتحديدا الاستناق بالغاز المسيل للدموع
عولجت ميدانيا العمليه العسكريه
الاسرائيليه فاطمه بالمجمل
استغرقت اقل من ساعه ونجم عنها بحسب بيان
للجيش الاسرائيلي انها حققت اهدافها
باعتقال اثنين من المطلوبين من البلده
القديمه في مدينه نابلس شكرا لك من نابلس
مراسل العربيه خالد قاسم على كل هذه
المعلومات
الخارجيه الفلسطينيه نددت بالهجمه
الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه واعتبرت انها
امتداد لحرب مفتوحه وتصعيد خطير يهدد
بتفجير الصراعي بالكامل وقالت الخارجيه في
بيانها مشاهدين ان مقتل 13 شخصا من
الفلسطينيين بينهم اطفال ونساء يعد
استمرار لمحاولات الحكومه الاسرائيليه
تصدير ازماتها للساحه الفلسطينيه وطالبت
الخارجيه طلبت المجتمع الدولي بتدخل عاجل
مؤكده ان الحل السياسي التفاوضي للصراع هو
المدخل الوحيد لتحقيق الامن والاستقرار في
ساحه النزاع من جانبه وصف وزير الامن
القومي الاسرائيلي اتمار بن غفير وصف
العمليه الامنيه التي شنتها قوات بلاده في
قطاع غزه بالبدايه الجديده داعيا الى
تغيير سياسه اسرائيل في القطاع ونقلا عن
صحيفه تايم قال بن غفير انه يهنئ رئيس
الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو على العمليه
الاستباقيه في غزه الى انها
بدايه موفقه وقرر بن غفير العوده للمشاركه
في التصويت على قرارات الحكومه
الاسرائيليه بعد ان كان قاطع عمليه
التصويت احتجاجا على سياسات بلاده تجاه
القطاع
[موسيقى]
مريم يلا
الصحفيه احمد حرب اهلا بك معنا احمد اذا
كنا نتحدث قبل قليل مع مراسلنا من الحدود
حدود غزه وكان نقل لنا التاهب الجوي
التاهب الاسرائيلي لاي هجمات من الفصائل
الفلسطينيه وخصوصا من الجهاد الاسلامي كيف
هو الوضع متى نتوقع الرد ان يكون وكيف
سيكون شكل هذا الرد احمد
يعني الان حركه
الثلاثه ودفهم وبعد ذلك من المتوقع ان
تبدا حركه الجهاد الاسلامي باطلاق
الصواريخ باتجاه المستوطنات والبلدات
الاستراليه المحاديه للقطاع ولربما هناك
سيناريو اخر ان تصل مدى هذه الصواريخ الى
تل ابيب
والقدس وهذا مما سوف يوسع رقعه الزيت
والتصعيد الاسرائيلي داخل القطاع ولربما
نصل الى تصعيد مفتوح او حرب خامسه على
قطاع غزه في حال يعني قطاعه الامور اكثر
من ذلك ولم تنجح الوصفات المصريه والامميه
في تهدئه الاوضاع في الساعات الاولى الان
كل العمل مركز على التشريع القاده الثلاث
وبعد ذلك سوف يكون يعني موقف من حركه
الجهاد الاسلامي اما بالتصعيد من خلال
اطلاق الصواريخ او سوف يتكون هناك كلمه
للناطق باسم سرايا القدس ابو حمزه اعلنت
عن اعلنت عنها حركه الجهاد الاسلامي بعد
قليل سوف يكون هناك كلمه للناطق باسم
سرايا القدس ابو حمزه ما تحمله هذه
الكلمات هي سوف تحدد شكل المشهد في
الساعات القادمه
والميدان في قطاع غزه هو سيد الموقف خلال
الساعات القادمه كما ذكرت اما ان يكون
هناك تصعيد شامل من القطاع من خلال اطلاق
الصواريخ من خلال حركه الجهاد الاسلامي
عبر الغرفه المشتركه للفصاله الفلسطينيه
او يكون هناك شكل اخر من
العسكريه لالفصائل الفلسطينيه في قطاع
احمد امام الفصائل الفلسطينيه غير التصعيد
يعني ذكرت بان هناك خيار التصعيد ولكن ما
الخيارات الاخرى التي تتحدث عنها امام
الفصائل الفلسطينيه يعني خصوصا وان مصر
تتوسط للتهدئه الان كما تشير الانباء
يعني كل الخيارات والاحتمالات مفتوحه
والسيناريوهات مفتوحه امام الرد على عمليه
الالتهاب من قبل حركه الجهاد الاسلامي كما
قالت حركه الجهد الاسلامي في بيانها الاول
عقب عمليه الاغتيال مباشره
الرعايه المصريه الان هي في موقف محرج ولن
يعني تحرز اي تقدم خلال الساعات القادمه
لان هناك عمليه استيال قاسيه لثلاثه قاده
عسكريين لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي وهذا
يستدعي رد اولي من حركه الجهاد الاسلامي
ميدانيا وعملاتيا ولكن
طبيعه هذا الرد
في تصريحات قبل قليل قالت ان
السرايا القدس تقول ان الرد لم يتاخر ولن
تتهاون امام هذه عمليه الاغتيال هو ان
الرد سوف يبدا من انتهت المعارف السابقه
مع اسرائيل وهذا يعني ان اطلاق الصواريخ
سوف يكون لمدى اوسع مما هو عليه في
التصعيدات السابقه ربما يصل كما ذكرت الى
القدس وتل ابيب وهنا سوف يكون رد فعل
اسرائيل
من خلال الغارات والاستهدافات واستهداف
يعني الابراج السكنيه والبنيه التحتيه في
القطاع هكذا نتوقع ولكن الوساطه المصريه
والرعايه المصريه حتى هذه اللحظه يعني
تجرى بشكل خجول لان
هناك اي رد من قبل الفصائل الفلسطينيه
لهذه الوصفات والرعايه المصريه او حتى
الامميه وايضا مصر قبل قليل ادانه هذا
عمليه الاغتلال واعتبرته يعني انتهاك
القواعد القانون الدولي وهو مرفوض حسب ما
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه المصريه وبالتالي
يعني في ظل هذه التهديدات والتحذيرات من
الجانبين هل بداوا بالفعل سكان المناطق
الحدوديه بالخروج من تلك المناطق والتهاب
لقرب الملاجئ كما طلب منهم
حتى هذه اللحظه يعني لم نشهد لم نشهد شيء
على ارض الواقع او شيء ملحوظ للاعلام وشيء
مرئي ولكن ما تقوم به العائلات الفلسطينيه
الذين يتقنون في المناطق الحدوديه
والشرقيه لقطاع غزه ربما يقوموا بشكل فردي
واستباقي ووقائي بالخروج من منازلهم
وباتجاه
والمغادره المنزل باتجاه الوسط يعني
وباتجاه وسط مدينه غزه ووسط القطاع خاصه
عندما نتحدث
نحن المناطق الشرقيه لخان يونس وحي
الشجاعيه
ورفح جنو
ب القطاع ربما تكون هناك يعني
حالات فرديه
من العائلات يعني الخروج من منازلهم
وتركها
خوفا من ان يكون هناك تصعيد اسرائيلي وقصف
اسرائيلي بشكل عشوائي للمنازل كما يحدث في
التصعيدات والحروب السابقه شكرا لك من غزه
صحفي احمد حرب
المكان منيح
[موسيقى]
يلا
نتابع
مع التصعيد العسكري في اوكرانيا غوتيريش
يستبعد واي مفاوضات سلام حاليا
اهلا بكم من جديد وصفه تدابير امنيه مشدده
احتفلت روسيا اليوم بذكرى الانتصار على
المانيا النازيه في الحرب العالميه
الثانيه بعرض في الساحه الحمراء في
العاصمه موسكو الاحتفال لم يكن كما اعتادت
عليه روسيا وذلك بسبب التاهب الامني في
اعقابي سلسله هجمات بطائرات المسيره بينها
الهجوم على الكرملين مدفع السلطات الروسيه
لالغاء بعض الفعاليات المصاحبه للاحتفال
السنوي خصوصا مع تزايد حده المواجهات في
الحرب مع اوكرانيا
وفي كلمته بعيد النصر قال الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين قال ان بلاده تواجه اليوم
حربا جديده تهدف الى اسقاط روسيا وتدميرها
وتفكيكها واضاف بوتين ان الشعب الاوكراني
اصبح
رهينه للنظام زيلينسكي ومخططات الغرب بحسب
تعبيره واشار الى ان الوضع الذي تمر به
اوكرانيا اليوم مسؤول عنه الغرب الذي يصدر
التوترات الى حدود روسيا
معنى من موسكو مراسل العربيه عبد الجواد
الرشد اهلا بك معنا عبد الجواد اذا كيف
اختلف احتفالات اليوم او احتفالات هذه
السنه عن سابقها خصوصا في ظل حده
الاشتباكات بين موسكو
مرحبا فاطمه نعم بالفعل يعني نسخه هذا
العام من الاحتفال بعيد النصر على النازيه
طبعا
مختلفه نوعا ما عن النسخات السابقه طبعا
لاحظنا وجود التشديد الامني الكبير في
كافه المناطق المحيطه بمبنى الكريم وبساحه
الحمراء طبعا عرض اليوم اقتصر على العروض
الارضيه طبعا لوحدات الجنود لبعض الاليات
العسكريه طبعا لكن ابتعد عن هذا العرض
العرض الجوي المعتاد الذي لم نلحظ اختفائه
منذ سنوات طبعا هذه هي الساحه الحمراء
فاطمه في هذا المكان يعني قبل نحو ربع
ساعه من الان مرت من هنا صواريخ يارس يعني
هذه الصواريخ الباليستيه التي يصل مداها
الى اكثر من 11
كيلومترا 11 الف كيلو متر فاطمه طبعا
الوضع هو مستقر نوعا ماركه ما نلاحظ هذه
هي الساحه الحمراء من هذا المكان كانت تمر
المعدات هذه هي المنصه الرئيسيه التي جلس
بها بوتين وضيوفه طبعا كان هناك تواجد
لرؤساء من الاتحاد السوفيتي السابق لبعض
الدول وبالمناسبه فاطمه هذه هي القبه طبعا
لمبنى الكريم التي تعرضت لضربات الدرون
قبل نحو ايامنا الان طبعا واسقطتها انظمه
الدفاع الجوي كما نلاحظ بان هذه القبه
تظهر بشكلها الطبيعي ولا شيء طبعا يعني
لا شيء ملحوظ بما يخص سقوط على العموم
فاطمه الوضع في موسكو مستقر نوعا ما هذا
الحفل يعني
ظهر اليوم مع تقليص بعض البرامج الجويه
لكن تقليص البرامج بما يخص حفل عيد النصر
في
يعني الاحتفالات بمدن واقاليم روسيا اقتصر
على عده مدن المنطقه الجنوبيه على سبيل
المثال اقتصرت العروض فيها كلها على مدينه
ارسطوف على نهر الدون فاطمه ماذا عن
الحضور عبد الجواد يعني هل رصدتم عدد
الحضور كما هو المعتاد كل سنه ام كان اقل
ام كان اكثر مدرسه
فاطمه بالارقام يعني عدد الجنود الذين
تواجدوا هنا في الساحه الحمراء زاد عن
اكثر من ثمانيه الاف جندي هذه المنصات ان
كانت المنصه اليمينيه او المنصه اليساريه
كانت ممتلئه بشكل كامل عدد الحضور يعني
يزيد عن ثلاثه الاف شخص بينما طبعا الفرق
الامنيه الواقفه على كل التفاصيل بدءا من
عمليات يعني يعني
البحث عن ليس عن اي شيء مخالف وانما تفتيش
كافه الامور كان عدد هائل كبير لم نعتاد
عليه في السابق لا في الساحه الحمراء ولا
في يعني اماكن دخولها عند نقاط التفتيش
لذلك طبعا فاطمه الوضع هو وضع طبيعي كما
يرى القائمون على هذا الموضوع خاصه يعني
مع ازمه المسيرات التي اصبحت تطال الكثير
من الامور في الساحه الحمراء او في المدن
الروسيه او غيرها من باقي المناطق لذلك
طبعا يعني فاطمه الوضع كما الان في الساحه
الحمراء هو مستقر بدات الناس بالخروج من
مداخل هذه الساحه كل هؤلاء الناس يعني
يعتبروا جزء بسيط مما شاهدناه هذه
المدرجات كانت ممتلئه بشكل الكامل
وبالمناسبه فاطمه يعني هذه هي زينه ساحه
الحمراء المعتاده لعيد النصر يعني تقوم
موسكو بتزيين مقر مبنى او المجمع التجاري
الجوم الذي يقع في الساحه الحمراء بهذه
الشاكله من كل عام لذلك هذا هو الفضع
فاطمه هذه الساحه الحمراء طبعا الجميع كان
يتحسن بان موسكو ستقدم على ضربات قاسيه في
بعض النقاط في الاراضي الاوكرانيه لكن حتى
هذه اللحظه الاخبار والتقارير الوارده من
هناك لا تتحدث عن هذا الشيء
سنتحدث تحديدا عن هذه الهجمات الروسيه عن
اوكرانيا على اوكرانيا شكرا لك من موسكو
مراسل العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد
اذا تزامنا مع احتفالات روسيا بعيد النصر
مشاهدينا واصلت موسكو هجماتها المكثفه على
اوكرانيا حيث اعلن مسؤولون ان روسيا اطلقت
نحو خمسه عشر صاروخ كروز على العاصمه كييف
لكن انظمه الدفاع الجوي اسقطتها
في انحاء البلاد وفي وقت سابق اطلقت اجهزه
الطوارئ انذارات جويه في فينيسيا غرب
البلاد الى جميع المناطق الشرقيه وجنوبا
حتى خيرسون ومنطقه اوديسا المطله على
البحر الاسود وتاتي هجمات اليوم الثلاثاء
بعدما اطلقت روسيا اكبر هجماتها بالطائرات
المسيره حتى الان في اطار حمله جويه
بداتها قبل ايام
منك ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل
اهلا بك معنا حذيفه اذا في حين ان موسكو
تحتفل بعيد النصر ما زالت ضربات مكثفه على
ما يبدو على العاصمه كييف هل هناك اي
هجمات متوقعه من الجانب الاوكراني على
الاراضي التي احتلتها روسيا
تحياتي فاطمه في الحقيقه نعم كان هنالك
ضربات نحو الاراضي الاوكرانيه في الليله
الماضيه بدات منذ عشيه الامس في العاشره
مساء بدات هذه الضربات واستمرت بعد ذلك
ايضا كان هنالك ضربه اخرى يعني كانت
موجتين الموجه الثانيه كانت في الرابعه
صباحا استهدفت الاراضي الاوكرانيه بحوالي
30 صاروخا اسقطت الدفاعات الجويه معظم هذه
الصواريخ حتى الان لم تسجل اصابات بين
المدنيين ايضا حتى الاصابات في البنيه
التحتيه خاصه في العاصمه كيف هي طفيفه جدا
طبعا الاحتفال بعيد النصر هو احتفال
سوفيتي واوكرانيا هي من ضمن الدول التي
كانت تحتفل بعيد النصر في التاسع من مايو
انا هنا فاطمه اقف حيث النصب التذكاري
للجنود المجهولين هذا هو المكان الذي ياتي
اليه الاوكرانيون في كل عام لاحياء ذكرى
الجنود الذين قاتلوا في هذه الحرب هذا
النصف يشهد الاحتفالات منذ اليوم يعني منذ
تاريخ عيد النصر وحتى قبل الحرب كان بشكل
مستمر يكون هنالك احتفال تحتفل الدوله
الاوكرانيه بشكل رسمي ايضا كان هنالك في
شارع الخرشات كشارع الرئيسي في العاصمه في
مركز المدينه كان يشهد عرض عسكري كما هو
موجود في موسكو وفي غيرها من الدول الان
الصوره تختلف تماما طبعا لاحظنا في العام
الماضي وكنا هنا في ذات المكان ونقلنا على
الهواء مباشره كيف هو الوضع كان يعني
يتوافد اعداد قليله من الناس غالبيتهم من
كبار السن من الذين عاشوا في حقبه الاتحاد
السوفيتي وهم مؤمنون بالقضيه السوفيتيه
وهم يعني
يعتقدون وهم طبعا ايضا ناقمون على الوضع
الحالي في
العلاقه كذلك بين اوكرانيا وبين
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والغرب وكذلك
ايضا يتوافد الى هنا اسر الذين قضوا في
التي كانت بين الاتحاد السوفيتي وبين
النازيه خاصه اولئك الذين كانوا في اسرتهم
من الضباط ومن الجنود الذين حاربوا في هذه
الحرب ياتون الى هنا لاحياء ذكرى اقاربهم
واهلهم الذين قاتلوا في صفوف الجيش
الاتحاد السوفيتي كما تلاحظين هنا في
الصوره يوجد عدد من الضباط في جيش الاتحاد
السوفيتي هنا مباشره اذا سمحت لي ساتحدث
الى هذا النقيب هو نقيب طيار قاتل في جيش
الاتحاد السوفيتي ويعني يعني هو اتى الى
هنا يحمل الورود كما ترين النياشين على
صدره واتى لاحياء الذكرى سالته طبعا
تعلمين ان هنالك تغيير يعني قدم رئيس
مشروع قانون للبرلمان الاوكراني تغيير يوم
الاحتفال من التاسع من مايو الى الثامن من
مايو يعني ساساله عن الاحتفال وعن رايه في
الحرب وكذلك ساساله عن التغيير هذا عن هذا
القانون الذي
وهو نقيب في الجيش الاتحاد السوفيتي وكان
طيارا ساساله الان عن يعني لماذا اتى الى
هنا اي ذكرى سوف يحيي ولماذا وما هو رايه
في استصدار قانون لتغيير يوم
الاحتفالات
وهو يقول انا اتيت الى هنا لاحيي ذكرى
الجنود والمقاتلين الذين قضوا في الحرب
العالميه وقاموا
بالحرب ضد النازيه وهو يقول انا ايضا انه
يعني هذا القانون بالنسبه له يعني سلبي
جدا وهو غير موافق عليه
يعني هو يقول الثامن من مايو تحتفل به
اوروبا هؤلاء الذين انتصرنا عليهم لديهم
هذه ذكرى فقط ولكن لدينا هو عيد النصر
ولذلك دائما سنحتفل في التاسع حذيفه يعني
رغم الحروب ورغم الهجمات الروسيه المكثفه
على العاصمه الا انهم ما زالوا يحتفلون
بهذه الذكرى ويزورون هذا المكان لذكرى عيد
النصر شكرا جزيلا
لك مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل كنت معنا من
كييف
اعرب الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
غوتيريش اعرب عن اسفه بسبب صعوبه اجراء
مفاوضات السلام بين اوكرانيا وروسيا في
الوقت الحالي موضحا لصحيفه البايس
الاسبانيه ان كلا الجانبين او كلا
الجانبين مقتنعان بامكانيات الانتصار
وعليه فلن تكون هناك اي بوادر لتحقيق
انجاز فوري لوقف اطلاق النار في المستقبل
القريب
اما الاتحاد الاوروبي مشاهدينا يخطط لفرض
حزمه جديده من العقوبات على اكثر من 35
شركه من ايران والصين والامارات وكذلك
ارمينيا واوزباكستان بسبب دعمهما للمجمع
الصناعي العسكري لروسيا وذلك بحسب وكاله
نقلا عن وثائق تابعه للمفوضيه الاوروبيه
كما تقترح الحزمه الجديده فرض عقوبات على
حوالي 70 فردا لم تحدد الوكاله اسمائهم
وجنسيتهم يعتزم الاتحاد الاوروبي فرض
عقوبات جديده لمكافحه التحايل على القيود
الحاليه والمتعلقه بتصدير منتجات
التكنولوجيا الفائقه والسلع ذات الاستخدام
المزدوج الى روسيا وقد تخضع شركات
تكنولوجيا المعلومات الروسيه والمتعاونه
مع جهاز الامن الفيدرالي قد وكذلك بعض
وسائل الاعلام الروسيه قد تخضع
للعقوبات الاوروبيه
بموازاته ذلك افادت مصادر لوكاله
الاتحاد الاوروبي اقترح حضر الوصول الى
موانئه للسفن التي تحاول التحايل على
العقوبات المفروضه على النفط الروسي حيث
يسعى الاتحاد الاوروبي الى وقف نقل الخام
من روسيا ومنتجاتها النفطيه التي تباع
باسعار ادنى من سقف السعر الذي حددته
مجموعه الدول السبع وذلك وفق ما نقلتهبل
كما ياتي هذا الاجراء مشاهدينا كجزء من
حزمه اوسع من العقوبات الاوروبيه على
روسيا في اعقاب حربها مع اوكرانيا
نستمر معكم ونتابع
ازمه دبلوماسيه تتصاعد بين الصين وكندا
فما القصه نتابع في الثامنه
[موسيقى]
اسرائيل تتاهب على حدود غزه بعد غارات على
القطاع قتله 13 فلسطينيا بينهم ثلاثه من
قاده الجهاد
حركه الجهات تتوعد اسرائيل برد سريع
والخارجيه الفلسطينيه تطالب بتدخل دوليا
عاجل لوقف التصعيد
وتزامنا مع غارات غزه القوات الاسرائيليه
تقتحم البلده القديمه في نابلس وتشتبك مع
فلسطينيين
روسيا تحتفل بعيد النصر وتواصل حمله
الغارات المكثفه على اوكرانيا والاخيره
تعلن التصدي للهجمات
احييكم من جديد قال قائد الجيش السوداني
الفريق اول ركن عبد الفتاح البرهان خلال
اتصال هاتفي بالرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان قال ان الجيش منفتح على اي مبادره
تسهم في تخفيف الاعمال التي وصفها
بالوحشيه من قبل الدعم السريع ومن جانبه
اعرب الرئيس التركي عن شكره لحكومه
السودان على تقديمها الدعم للسفير
والجاليه التركيه
وموافقتها على نقل السفاره الى بورتسودان
كما طلب اردوغان المساعده في نقل بقيه
الجاليه التركيه من الخرطوم وانيالا الى
بورسودان
[موسيقى]
اما ميدانيا فقد تجددت الاشتباكات بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في
مناطق عده بالخرطوم حيث ارتفعت اعمده
الدخان في العاصمه في وقت يجتمع ممثلون عن
الجيش والدعم السريع في جده لبحث وقف
اطلاق النار وفتح ممرات انسانيه وبحث سبل
لانهاء الازمه وكان مراسل العربيه افاد
باشتباكات جرت صباح اليوم في ام درمان
والخرطوم وافاد بسماع اصوات مضاء او اصوات
مضادات في وقت حلقت فيه الطائرات بسماء
العاصمه
قال والي ولايه البحر الاحمر ان مدينه
بورسودان استقبلت عددا كبير من المواطنين
ومنسوبيين منظمات الدوليه واضاف ان 98
دوله اجنبيه اجلت رعاياها الى خارج
السودان
العدد كبير جدا من الاخوان
العايدين او
بلدانهم من مختلف جنسيات من
دبلوماسيين مواطنين منسوبين منظمات عالميه
معنا من ام درمان الصحفي في مكتب العربيه
بالسودان شهدي نادر اهلا بك معنا شهدي اذا
في ظل المفاوضات التي تجري في جده ما زالت
انباء تتحدث عن اشتباكات قائمه بين
الطرفين الجيش والدعم السريع ما التوقعات
الدائره في داخل السوداني عن نجاح هذه
المفاوضات من عدمه
مرحب نعم اليوم تجددت
الاشتباكات طلعت جويه منذ صباح
الباكره اصوات مضادات ارضيه حتى قبل دقائق
قليله كانت تدوي هنا من شرق مدينه ام
درمان اشتباكات في محيط القصر الجمهوري
ومحيط السوق العربي
اعمده الدخان تتصاعد من عده نقاط في
العاصمه المثلثه منذ هذا الصباح عوده الى
سؤالك حول التوقعات مما يجري في
جده في اطار المبادره السعوديه الامريكيه
شعبيا يضع السودانيين اعمال استطلعناهم
بالامس تحدثنا معهم يضعوا عليها امال في
ان تفلح في ان تفلح في ان تؤدي الى تهدئه
العمليات العسكريه وايجاد حل ينهي معاناه
السودانيين التي لها حوالي شهر من
منذ الى هذه الاشتباكات السودانيين يعملون
ان ان تنجح هذه هذه المفاوضات في ايجاد
هدنه متماسكه الى حد كبير علهم يستطيعون
انغاز الوضع الانساني المتدهور الظروف
الصعبه التي هابات يعيشها السودانيون
السودانيين ليس على صيد العمليات العسكريه
وانما على تاثير التاثيراتها
لخدماتهم الاساسيه من مياه وكهرباء
واتصالات وسيله اساسيه وكل ذلك
من السودان حتى الان
صحيا الوضع يمضي في تحسن ولكن هو طفيف
وعبر مجهودات هناك جهد رسمي وكذلك يكمله
جهد شعبي المستشفيات ما تزال بها نواقص
هناك مساعدات طبيه وصلت الى امنه بورسودان
من عده منظمات والدول اللجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر كانت قد بادرت بايصال
ثمانيه اطنان الى ميناء بورتسودان ولكنها
اطالبت بضمان فتح مسار امن حتى تتمكن من
ايصالها الى المستشفيات العمليات العسكريه
تعيق ايصال المساعدات الطبيه والمساعدات
الانسانيه الى من يحتاجونها كذلك هناك
قطوعات في المياه عن عدد من احياء العاصمه
المثلثه هناك احطاء في محطات
المياه الشرب على على نهر النيل ولكن ليس
بصير ما يزال
عصيا على المهندسين وفرق الصيانه ان تصل
الى هذه المحطات وان تقوم بصيانتها واعاد
[موسيقى]
اعلنت الخارجيه الكنديه مشاهدينا طرده
دبلوماسيا صيني تتهمه اوتاوى بالسعر تهريب
نائب كندي وعائلته على خلفيه انتقادات
وجهها الى بكين والاخيره ردت بالمثل وقالت
وزيره الخارجيه الكنديه ميلاني جولي في
بيان ان بلادها قررت اعلان تشاو وي شخصا
غير مرغوب فيه على الاراضي الكنديه وان
كندا لن تتسامح مع اي شكل من اشكال التدخل
في شؤونها الداخليه وتم تحذير دبلوماسيين
في كندا من انهم اذا انخرطوا في هذا النوع
من السلوك فسيتم طردهم
الى امريكا والتي استدعى فيها البيت
الابيض الاسبوع الماضي استدعى رؤساء شركات
التكنولوجيا الذين ابلغوا بضروره حمايه
الجمهور من مخاطر الذكاء الاصطناعي وبان
عليهم واجب اخلاقي لحمايه المجتمع واوضح
البيت الابيض مشاهدينا انه قد ينظم القطاع
بشكل اكبر خاصه بعد الحوادث والمشاكل التي
بدات تظهر من وراء الذكاء الاصطناعي
الثوره الكبيره التي نراها ونعيشها في
عالمنا اليوم مع الذكاء الاصطناعي بدات
تتكشف مساوئها وبدات تظهر مخاطرها الامثله
اصبحت كثيره من عمليات الاحتيال عبر
الهاتف الى صور مفبركه واليوم هناك مستوى
جديد مخيف
دوستيفانو الام المذهوله تخبر كيف استخدم
مجموعه من المجرمين الذكاء الاصطناعي
لاستنساخ صوت ابنتها
قدرها مليون دولار كجزء من مخطط صوتي جديد
مرعب
وجدت على الهاتف ولم اشك ابدا في انها
كانت هي هذا هو الجزء الفظيع الذي اوصلني
حقا الى الانهيار وعندما حاولت الاتصال
بهاتفها اجابته على الرغم من انها كانت في
صف التزلج في ولايه اخرى ليتضح بانها ليست
مخطوفه
تاتي هذه القنبله وسط زياده في مخططات
انتحال هويه المتصل او حتى في الاعمال
المزوره كصوره البابا فرنسيس بابا روما
هنا الذي يظهر كا ايقونه الموضه لهذا
الموسم وقد يذهب الامر الى مستوى خطيرا
كهذه الحاله التي تم تسجيلها في بلجيكا
عندما اقدم رجل على الانتحار بعدما تحدث
الى شيء روبوت الدردشه في تطبيق الذكاء
الاصطناعي
لا نريد ايضا ان تقوم برامج الدردشه
الاليه بالترويج لعادات الاكل غير الصحيه
او الاتجاه على اساءه استخدام العقاقير
وبعد الكثير من الحوادث تم تعديل هذه
البرامج من قبل الشركات التي تنتج هذه
التطبيقات ولذا اعتقد ان هناك متسعا
لمطوري هذه الانظمه لانشاء حواجز الحمايه
التي نرغب في رؤيتها
عندما جربنا التطبيق الذي يعمل على نموذج
لغه ذكاء اصطناعي مفصل لم يشجع على
الانتحار ما يعني ان القائمين على التطبيق
عدلوا بالمحتوى بعد الحادثه في بلجيكا
الجدل داير الان على اعلى المستويات في
الولايات المتحده حول مخاطر الذكاء
الاصطناعي الاداره الامريكيه القلب
المسؤوليه على عاتقي شركات التكنولوجيا
وكبار رواد هذا القطاع منقسمون بين مؤيدا
للذكاء ومعارض له كونه خطرا على البشريه
ريتا سليمان العربيه واشنطن
قبل الختام نذكر بالعناوين
اسرائيل تتاهب على حدود غزه بعد غارات على
القطاع قتلت 13 فلسطينيا بينهم ثلاثه من
قاده الجهاد
حركه الجهاد تتوعد اسرائيل برد سريع
والخارجيه الفلسطينيه تطالب بتدخل دولي
عاجل لوقف التصعيد
وتزامنا مع غارات غزه القوات الاسرائيليه
تقتحم البلده القديمه في نابلس وتشتبك مع
فلسطينيين
روسيا تحتفل بعيد النصر وتواصل حمله
الغارات المكثفه على اوكرانيا والاخيره
تعلن التصدي للهجمات
وصلنا الى ختام هذه النشره الاخباريه في
الاحمر يلتقيكم على راس الساعه في امان
الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات